[Musik]
die grinsekatze die tea party die
herzkönigin der merzhauser und der
verrückte hutmacher
sie alle stammen aus der geschichte
alice im wunderland einem der
bekanntesten kinderbücher der welt
das victoria and albert museum in london
widmet der berühmten erzählung eine
ganze ausstellung die in kulturellen
einfluss der geschichte unter die lupe
nimmt
[Musik]
warum es so eine faszination ausübt
lässt sich kaum beantworten es ist ein
so großes weltweites phänomen
das buch wurde 1865 veröffentlicht und
wir sind immer noch davon begeistert mit
dieser ausstellung versuchen wir die
frage zu beantworten wie und warum er
lässt zu diesem phänomen geworden ist
nicht nur in der literatur sondern
überall auch in film kunst design
fotografie mode wissenschaft mathematik
in jedem lebensbereich lässt sich
irgendwo ein bezug zu alice finden
ihren ursprung hat die kindergeschichte
im jahr 1862 im britischen oxford
inspiriert von den wissenschaftlichen
errungenschaften der damaligen zeit er
findet der universitätsdozent charles
watson die erzählung für die damals
zehnjährige erlitt mittel die tochter
eines freundes
drei jahre später veröffentlicht er die
fantasievolle geschichte als buch unter
dem pseudonym louis campbell der beginn
eines mythos
die reise von alles ist so eindrucksvoll
wie ist eine sehr willens starke helden
sie ist mutig neugierig stur und
abenteuerlustig wir können von den
botschaften des buches immer noch lernen
es ist immer noch inspirierend sie ist
ein unglaublich ermutigendes und starkes
vorbild
das buch wurde unzählige male verfilmt
darunter der us-amerikanischen walt
disney klassiker aus dem jahr 1951 oder
die version des us-amerikanischen
regisseurs tim burton aus dem jahr 2010
die figuren und erlebnisse der zeitlosen
kindergeschichte bieten schier endlose
möglichkeiten für interpretationen
das war auch die herausforderung für den
renommierten britischen bühnenbildner
tom piper hier zu hause in seinem büro
er hat die räume der gesamten
ausstellung gestaltet ich fand es
zugleich schwierig und aufregend meine
eigenen vorstellungen zu dem buch zu
entwickeln wie die idee mit dem pier am
meer der sich in eine raupe verwandelt
ich habe einen pier gezeichnet mit
spindeldürren beinen der sich aufrichtet
und zur haupt worden
es hat spaß gemacht etwas zu gestalten
dass es so nicht im buch gibt aber davon
inspiriert wurde um die reise in alice
welt einzuleiten orientiert sich der
designer zum beispiel am viktorianischen
streben nach wissen er kreiert eine
bibliothek die zum leben erwacht und in
der buchseiten durch den raum schweben
ich habe tatsächlich alle mittel
verwendet die ich auch im theater
einsätze um eine art immer sie will welt
in der ausstellung zu erschaffen
ich hoffe dass die leute sich wirklich
so fühlen als wären sie in den
kaninchenbau gefallen und nach einem
fantastischen ergebnis wieder
herauskommen voller fragen vielleicht
und hoffentlich auch staunen
zurück im museum vom surrealismus und
psychedelischer kunst der 1960 er jahre
über politisches bis hin zu fotografie
mode und bühnenkostüm die geschichte von
alice im wunderland hat fast alle
bereiche der kultur inspiriert und
beeinflusst
die zukunft von alice ist völlig offen
ich bin mir sicher dass sich das
phänomen immer weiter entwickeln wird
und ich finde es aufregend dass wir
quantenphysiker haben die sich die
theorien im buch anschauen
modedesigner wie iris van herpen die
sich mit den theorien von raum und zeit
beschäftigen um die grenzen des designs
zu springen
ich bin sehr gespannt was noch passieren
wird bereits heute ist es in der
ausstellung dank modernster technik
möglich charaktere aus dem buch zu
treffen mit einer virtual reality brille
können besucherinnen und besucher die
herzkönigin bei einer partie crockett
schlagen
[Musik]